i remember banana saying um
it's like giving a kid a gun in the hand
and not telling them what to do about it
like because i understand how easily
your life could like spiral out control
like i could feel it happening
i'm jane park and winning lottery made
me miserable
so at this time that i won i was loving
my mum in two bedroom council flat and i
was working at scottish council for
volunteer organizations i was on like
eight pounds an hour but at that time
like that was a really good wage i was
17 so i already thought i was like
falling a bit so
it was a sunday afternoon and i'd been
out friday
and i basically remembered about my
lottery ticket and i was like oh my god
i might have won a million pounds and i
went to check the ticket and millionaire
matchmaker matched the code i had on my
ticket so from banana man i was like
take it to the shop keep it hidden like
sort of ran to the shop
first in the shop didn't even wait in
the queue like i was like can you check
my lottery ticket so the guy checked it
was like a think of one i was like
charlie from charlie in the chocolate
factory it was literally like that ran
back and i was like to my mom i need to
use the house phone like and then they
just said congratulations you've run a
million pound and i remember just
thinking oh my god and i remember just
sitting there thinking like i am simon
kimmel like i am a millionaire like what
happens after you win the lottery like
what's the process is it a bit of a
whirlwind it's a bit like crazy that
first couple weeks you're told like
camelot we're saying don't tell anyone
while i was still on the phone at
camelot and they were telling me i was
one i was writing a facebook status i'm
like no one's going to believe me but
i've actually won a million friends in
the lottery i remember my mates being
like
you're crazy but i knew it was going to
come in the media so i was like whatever
people always say to me like did you go
to the atm and see a million pounds in
your bank like it's no even like that
basically goes on a private bank you
just contact them and they transfer your
money into your normal bank as and when
you want or need it what is happening in
this photo what's going on
so this was like the press
part after you
like wins finalizing stuff so there's
loads of like press there there's
journalists
the bags were empty so basically they
want to tell me to look like this young
girl who had all this that's the dress
it's from asda i'm standing there and i
remember
i was that young like i couldn't even
have the champagne i had glass iron room
and i was like
like this i was literally like surreal
like i felt like a celebrity and i still
have the check and stuff like it's mad i
probably thought i was like a
billionaire
i thought it was simon cowell i thought
i was going to be on yours like have big
mansions and that it's nowhere near like
that it's mummy and pan you must have
like
gone a bit like mad in that first year
so like i did go a bit mad as in like
what loads of like designer clothes
and buy bags and buy shoes i've bought
like quite a few cars i used to go out
quite a lot maybe like three or four
times a week i would buy tables or buy
bottles i was going on holiday a lot i
remember i went to magaluf and i
when i went in this bar and the dj knew
i was and he had said if you get my name
tattoos on you he was like i'll give you
three um drinks in the bar for like a
week or something so i went straight
over the road to the tattoo shop and got
his name tatted on my bum and like why
would i do that the drinks for like a
year or a drink and i just want a
million friends like what but here i was
thinking february that's that's about me
like i had a few weeks of like partying
and then mates and i filmed the
documentary and it was very much woo
and then one of my family members was
like look now it's time like to be
sensible like
maybe buy property so i bought a house
remember like hitting all this this
brand new building and i remember just
sitting there like what am i doing like
i was in a three bedroom house by myself
like there was nothing like i was just
bored i just wasn't ready to grow up at
that time i mean that's fair enough
you're 17 and you just won a million
pounds
how did everything change so basically i
went from being this young 17 year old
going to work every day i saw this like
massive
household name like journalists standing
outside my house waiting on me coming
out there was paps on the other side of
the road they were hiding in bushes they
were outside my work they would
literally have just done anything to get
a story whether it was good or bad
i think i went to like an event and i'd
be fine i came back and someone has
someone had wrote calling them a picture
are you pregnant and i remember thinking
why would i be on a grasshopper and i'd
be for a drink and if i was pregnant
like obviously no pregnant but by the
time i got back to my phone or back to
the hotel and had like seen it all
there was a there was a story in the in
the media and it just blew up like i've
had some horrific messages and the media
do play a massive part in that because
they choose the photos they pick they
choose what they're writing i feel like
they may even play a massive part in
like my self-consciousness in my body
and if they had a probable left melon i
would have won't need all this cosmetic
surgery and and i feel like they'd never
take responsibility so you mentioned
there that you've had a bit of cosmetic
surgery uh so
i have had a boob job
and i've had two bbls so two episodes
one left they're the only like ones that
went under the knife and i have a little
bit of lip filler
and i've had botox a couple of times
look at my forehead obviously got my
first bbl
that went like horrifically wrong what
happened how did it all go wrong i came
home from turkey i got done turkey and i
was very unwell i went up to the
hospital the blue light is me to another
hospital i was hooked up on drips and i
ended up having likes
except to see me i remember like being
in there for like a month and when i got
to the hospital on the first night she
was like if you had have left that 24
hours later like it could have been
fatal and i remember thinking
like
i could have died and you did another
similar procedure again after that yeah
done the exact same procedure again you
must be so scared i know i was i was
literally petrified but i remember
thinking i hated my body again and i was
constantly in the media again i went to
dubai on the second lockdown i remember
coming back and i had to stop and turkey
and i was like
just make me feel better again and now
like i'm very happy with my body going
up holiday and stuff i feel much more
confident getting in like a swimsuit to
know that i feel good in myself like
it vibrates often men i feel like people
get a better
impression of me but i think people
think that like i've had masses of
surgery when i've actually know
they always do this thing where they
transform me from when i first won the
lottery
all these pictures every year and i
understand the con the difference is
massive but people grow up even when if
you take a photo of someone when they're
17 and look at them in 26 they they look
different anyway regardless if they've
got a million pound donut
and there was a
moment for you you were like actually
like all of these amazing things have
happened i've won a million pounds but
i'm not sure i'm very happy can you tell
me about that so i remember just like
feeling very lonely i felt like all my
mates were always working press was
coming too much like
it just all became too much i remember
when people were trying to speak to me
and stuff like i was just questioning
everyone's intentions like i wasn't
necessarily thinking they wanted my
money but i was thinking like you would
never have chatted to me before and
how's it impacted on your love life it
has obviously impacted it because every
time a guy tries to speak to me i always
try and think would you have chatted to
me if i hadn't won the lottery then i
always think like i wouldn't look the
way i look if i hadn't won the lottery
so i'm like it affects me even slows
mistakes i have massive trust issues
just wondering on what people's
intentions are how miserable did it make
you so it literally became to a point
where i was like i hate this like i
remember thinking i'm so young and like
why would anyone put someone this young
through these emotions because like i
remember bananas and um
it's like giving a kid a gun in the hand
and not telling them what to do about it
like
because i understand how easily your
life could like spill out control like i
could feel it happening and you actually
eventually tried to sue camelot so i
actually never even ever tried to sue
camelot i just i say that because it's a
bold thing to say i knew it was going to
catch people's attention
and like at the time
i was basically just saying like how is
it 16 to play the lottery but 18 a
gamble and as a former gambling like you
could easily become addicted to trying
to win the lottery the age has just
recently been changed i know for a fact
my voice has an input on that because i
brought it to everyone's attention
when the story came out that i was going
to sue oh i literally had the worst
amount of like abuse online people were
saying like die like i had acid attack
fix like it was literally
hectic like people were hating on me and
i was just this young girl who just
wanted to be hard like remember
feeling like
my life was like i just felt like this
is
not what i thought it was going to be
like
i thought it was going to be like
amazing like i was going to be this big
massive celebrity i was going to be all
constantly on red carpets and stuff and
like i was literally sitting in a
three-bedroom house alone like crying
myself to sleep do you still feel like
that or do you feel happier in yourself
you have good days and you have bad days
like there's times where i feel lonely
and i feel bored and i feel
but there's other times where i'm like
flying to dubai and i'm doing nice
things like and i'm very grateful for
the life that i've left i've been places
i would never been able to go
i've met people that i would never have
met
and like i do feel incredible incredibly
grateful i still get shocked now meeting
and seeing new things like so the
question everyone must end up asking you
is are you still a millionaire i still
have a lot of money i have investments
and i would just ne i would never speak
about
direct figures i never want to seem like
i'm too flashy so i would rather just
keep it to myself and my account and
then i'm happy with that
how much money did you win on the
lottery
i won
6.1 million jesus i'm a trained engineer
but i was made redundant when i was
working as a bus driver in north staff
south cheshire i remember this story on
the news that's right yes how about you
just a meal for me